so muss man das sehen ja ok und 31 wir
sind sehr schön
ja wir sind live beim zweiten live sehen
hier auf klicks um science-fiction toll
dass er da seid und das ereignis ist
leider ein trauriges wir sehen es hier
nicht mehr im hintergrund aber das
machen wir jetzt mal das ist der tod von
stephen hawking hat zumal gerade warte
mal wenn du sitzen ist kaum gewehrt und
genau da sehen was das ist wirklich ein
verlust für die menschheit muss man
sagen den wir so zumindest seit dem ich
lebe nicht mehr erlebt haben es ist ein
wissenschaftler von uns gegangen der
wirklich absolut bahnbrechendes
geleistet hat für die physik und ganz
ganz wichtige erkenntnisse geliefert hat
zum schwarzen löchern zu zum universum
generell und viele hatten gehofft dass
er mal
ich sag mal die gottesformel findet dass
er quantenphysik und relativitätstheorie
vereint das er
ich sag mal die formel für alles findet
das wird jetzt auf keinen fall mehr
stattfinden wobei er seinen lehrstuhl in
cambridge im früher übrigens mal isaac
newton inne hatte schon 2009 verlassen
hat und in letzter zeit hat er durch
viele viele viele verschiedene thesen
für aufmerksamkeit gesorgt
da geht es zum beispiel um ki die
gefährlichkeit von künstlicher
intelligenz da ging es darum dass wir
vielleicht schon bald die erde verlassen
müssen
also er war immer auch gerne provokant
und hat den gesalzenen finger in die
wunde gelegt und vielleicht auch ein
wenig übertrieben zuweilen aber es war
auf jeden fall ein ein unglaubliches man
muss es sagen gehirn der wahnsinnige
dinge durchdacht hat und ob das mit
seiner krankheit zusammenhängen von der
er selber gesagt hat bei mir
funktioniert nichts mehr außer meinen
kopf aber der eben vielleicht sogar
besser als bei vielen vielen anderen
menschen er ist einer der führenden
physiker gewesen
in auf der welt wenige gab es und gibt
es von seinem format vielleicht ein
zweiter arbeit ein stein der viele viele
thesen entwickelt hat auf der viele
erkenntnisse heute basieren und zum
beispiel ich habe darüber ja diverse
videos gemacht
eine ganz wichtige geschichte ist dass
schwarze löcher eben nicht für ewig
existieren dass sie halt nicht für immer
die materie anziehen sondern dass sie
eine hawking strahlung die wurde nach
ihm benannt aussenden und durch dieses
aussenden dieser strahlung allmählich
auch ihren inhalt verlieren und sich auf
über kurz oder lang das ist ein paar
schwarzen löchern auch noch ganz ganz
bezeichnend dass sie wahrscheinlich
selber im inneren durch die irrsinnige
gravitation einen viel kürzeren zeitraum
wahrnehmen indem sie existieren als wir
ihnen von außen deswegen zeit im
schwarzen loch ist ganz anders als
außerhalb des schwarzen loches dass sie
über kurz oder lang halt verschwinden
werden und darauf basiert zb die
hypothese dass muss man sagen dass
vielleicht das universum eine dass wir
ein programm sind und wie bei einem
schwarzen loch die informationen in
wirklichkeit auf dem ereignishorizont
existieren ja er hat viele viele
bahnbrechende erkenntnisse gewonnen
zum einen hat er die singularität
nachgewiesen im in schwarzen löchern
mathematisch er hat ein modell für das
universum gefunden das ich sag mal
erklärt warum das universum wir haben
das gerade vor kurzem wo es noch mal im
interview erklärt hat und noch mal so
auf den punkt gebracht hat dass das
universum eben wahrscheinlich nicht im
urknall entstanden ist dass der urknall
schon ist
diesen rucksack aber er ist wie auf der
erdkugel am nordpol der ja auch ein ganz
bestimmter punkt ist aber man kann über
ihn drüber hinweggehen er ist nicht das
ende der welt und so stellt sich so oder
so hat
ich sag mal in einer wissenschaftlichen
arbeit hawking begründen können dass das
universum eine 4 dimensionale kugel ist
wo eben dieser urknall nur ein punkt auf
der hülle der kugel ist und das ist da
sind wirklich gedankengänge und das muss
man sagen das sind gedankengänge das ist
nicht so einfach so was erstens zu
überhaupt diese ideen zu entwickeln und
dann auch noch in theoretische arbeiten
zu fassen da ist ja wirklich ein absolut
einmaliger physiker gewesen ja nicht
umsonst diesen lehrstuhl in cambridge
innehatte und damit eben zu den absolut
führenden physikern weltweit gehört
hatte und als heute morgen dann die
nachricht kam dass stephen hawking
gestorben seit da sind doch viele viele
menschen aus allen wolken gefallen weil
damit hat nun wirklich keiner gerechnet
weil er hatte ja seine krankheit weil es
schon viele jahrzehnte mehr überlebt als
man eigentlich damit gerechnet hatte und
deshalb war dieser droht dieses mannes
das war eigentlich undenkbar
und er hat ja auch für seine
verhältnisse unglaubliche abenteuer
erlebt er ist in star trek folgen
aufgetaucht er hat parabelflüge gemacht
also das was vielen körperbehinderten
gar nicht möglich ist das hat er gemacht
natürlich aufgrund auf seiner ganz
besonderen rolle und deshalb man kann
sagen mit ihm ist von uns gegangen ein
absoluter visionär der ich glaube für
die ganze menschheit eine große
bedeutung hatte und zwar in der form
dass er einfach horizonte geöffnet hatte
und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen hier
bei pixum immer wieder unser ansinnen
dass wir zeigen wollen was ist überhaupt
denkbar was ist möglich also nicht nur
die trockene wissenschaft sondern auch
so perspektiven eröffnen und dabei eben
auch jemand mit dem thema gesagt hat
hacker
die kann uns umbringen ist total
gefährlich ich hatte den tage erst
wieder mit einer kollegin intensive
diskussionen darüber
es ist nicht ganz von der hand zu weisen
wenn man sich zum beispiel hier auf
youtube den algorithmus anguckt der
einfach er lügen videos
verschwörungstheorien nach vorne bringt
und der algorithmus ist eine ki google
brain nennt sich das ganze auf dem
dieser algorithmus basiert und die
entwickler können hat gar nicht mehr
sagen warum diese algorithmus was macht
er arbeitet ja nur nach dem prinzip
zugucken wie lang wird ein video von
welchen zuschauer geguckt und
entsprechende videos werden diesen
zuschauer dann weiter empfohlen und das
sind halt über die masse der videos eben
er lügen und verschwörungstheorien nicht
umsonst laufen dann fletchers videos zum
beispiel wie holly und es ist natürlich
dann komplett erschreckend wenn man
sieht dass menschen sagen oh ich habe
ganz viel youtube-videos zudem an dem
thema gesehen jetzt weiß ich bescheid
weil ein zu sicher wenn man ganz viele
wie youtube videos gesehen hat der weiß
wann eine menge aber nicht bescheid weiß
nämlich was die leute alles erzählen und
nämlich mehr gerade diese verschwörung
die es ist mein lieblingsthema mal auf
ich würde jetzt sagen wir gehen mal in
den chats thomas ich werde erst mal
sagen dass ich mich vorstellen ich habe
die frage mich wer du bist ja ich gerade
lust viele leute okay also das ist
thomas in der kamera sieht man ich bin
hauptberuflich social media manager bei
christophs firma united
ich mache ich hier immer wenn es gerade
was ist dann mache ich den chat oder vor
der kamera dabei und stellt die fragen
die in den chats und beantworten und im
chat beifang und ja ich bin hier
freiwillig dabei das haben auch einige
leute gefragt am main also in
wirklichkeit eher hinten die schraube
geht ganz viel frei was ist der
festliche ist mit gift hinein
aber wie wir ob mich gibt ist er braucht
natürlich kannst du mal guckt das kabel
ist ja jetzt vor dem objektiv viel liebe
das ist ungünstig
dazu das ist natürlich ein weiteres
thema es gibt ja diese also zum beispiel
menschen aus asien vertragen ja wirklich
keine milch die sind laktoseintoleranz
und es gibt immer wieder die frage darf
man mit stricken ist was wirklich gesund
und das ist nur für die ersten
lebensjahre
das ist ein weites feld und man kann
natürlich zu vielen vielen dingen sagen
dass sie gift sind aber da gibt es auch
in der wissenschaft eine ganz einfach
erkenntnisse dazu es ist alles eine
frage der dosierung
ich kann zum beispiel sagen von meinem
bruder der dialyse patient war also der
keinen ihren mehr hatte die funktioniert
der hätte sich für den man tomaten gift
der hätte mit einem kilo tomaten hätte
der sich jederzeit umbringen können weil
da so wie natrium ist das hätte ihn
umgebracht weil das eben nicht mehr war
kein organ mehr da was das natrium
abgebaut hätte also gibt es immer eine
frage der menge
man kann alles zu sich nehmen auch arsen
ein richtiges kit mit dem man leute
umbringen kann aber in kleinen mengen
ist es halt anregend oder alkohol ist
auch gift natürlich mit alkohol kann man
sich einfach mal umbringen
ich rate zum beispiel nicht das zu
machen was ich in meinem alkohol video
gemacht habe wo ich dann am ende bei 4,0
promille war das war genau das war das
ist nicht so schlau und mehr ist dann
halt wirklich auch wirklich gefährlich
das geht dann die richtung also von
daher ist alles gift es ist eine frage
der dosierung wenn man natürlich ohne
ende milch trinkt wird das den körper
verändern das wird im körper reaktion
hervorrufen aber ich glaube in der menge
in dem man normalerweise milch trinkt
ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt mit dem
thema noch gar nicht beschäftigt wenn du
plötzlich im video das gift ist sie sich
auch er ist auch gift und luft dass auch
das alles gibt so ira der dosierung aber
die luft ist ein kurzes sauerstoff und
so weiter aber es war also dass man muss
dazu sagen alle leute sich jetzt darüber
aufregen simon meint das nicht ernst
dass so jemand meint dass nicht alles
fertig hatte das mit der milch ernst
gemeint aber den rest was jetzt kommt
ist auch mit chemtrails unseren ganzen
zorn und das ist nicht ernst heute nimmt
das bitte nicht ernst sollte jung und
beeinflussbar seien in indien in meinem
publikum über einen ja jeder schreibt
die ganze technik welches gift mich es
gibt ist mit
ich denke aber zu dem thema machen das
richtig kann sich ja mal wiederzukommen
mal gucken aber auf jeden fall mich ist
ja ja gibt es gibt es ist jenes ich habe
das sehr gute aussage ja ansonsten werde
ich ab und zu so zwischendurch mal
fragen gestellt wenn irgendwas genau die
fragen lasst uns aber stephen hawking
reden meine frage an euch wäre und das
schreibt bitte in die kommentare wie
bewertet ihr das hat das für euch eine
ähnliche bedeutung seid ihr auch so
heute morgen aus allen wolken gefallen
als die nachricht kam also mich hat es
echt umgehauen ich habe eine weile
gebraucht bis ich dann dazu gekommen bin
wirklich auch den text zu schreiben das
hat mich wirklich wirklich stark
emotional betroffen gemacht und fand es
wirklich sehr sehr traurig das ist so
eine epoche die zu ende geht er hat eben
seit den 60er jahren
weil da hat er seine ersten
bahnbrechenden arbeiten veröffentlicht
seit den 60er jahren eben die ganz den
ganzen forschungszweig beeinflusst eben
vor allem der astro für sich und ja das
ist dann schon das haut einen um bändern
so etwas passiert und ja wie ist das bei
euch gewesen jetzt da prasseln hier nur
noch irgendwie kommentare rein ich weiß
gar nicht wie machen dass leute die eine
million absagen macht dann immer so
einen langsamen mode ein aber das mach
ich das okay wird gut also ich kann hier
nichts mehr lesen es ist mit ist es ist
ja genau wie macht man den langsamen
mode das mache ich kurz app macht das
doch mal kurz
wir machen jetzt den langsam mond ein
der langsame mode kommt strich geht das
denn jetzt ist der youtube fragen nach
gott nicht er geht aber das kriegen wir
doch bestimmt schnell gleich hin ist
sogleich guckt man sonst hier mal in den
darf ich jeden chad kugler ist ein
problem in den chats ruhig aber nicht
auf die
der seite auf dem vier studios origins
wenig auf die studie seite also einfach
auf mein video kann ich gucken oder
nicht ja okay dann guck mal hier rein so
übrigen fan sind knapp 2000 zuschauer
das ist wirklich absolut irre hier geht
es jetzt zum beispiel hier ist du hast
ist es lustig das muss ich jetzt kommt
ja was für mensch der war kam jetzt hier
gerade eine frage das kann man natürlich
nicht überhaupt nicht so sagen es ist
geht es ist ja auch so dass ich sage mal
prominente oft für die öffentlichkeit
eine sehr wichtige rolle spielen und
dort wichtige dinge sagen wichtige
impulse geben aber privat einfach eine
katastrophe sind das gibt es natürlich
ich weiß es nicht er hat sich auch von
seiner frau getrennt hat seine pflegerin
geheiratet aber ich glaube von außen das
zu beurteilen das steht einem überhaupt
nicht zu warum privat jemand irgendetwas
macht ich kann das beurteilen was er
wissenschaftlich gemacht hat und das ist
einfach eben bahn brechen gewesen wir
würden viele dinge heute nicht denken
können ohne seine arbeiten und ob sie
nachher am ende wirklich zutreffen weil
das sehr theoretische arbeiten oder eben
nur ein schritt waren auf dem weg eben
zur wirklichen erkenntnis das werden wir
am ende sehen
da ist natürlich muss man sagen hier
quantenphysik und relativitätstheorie
das sind noch ganz andere meilenstein
dann muss man sagen weil die haben
wirklich die sind immer wieder bewiesen
worden also die beide obwohl sie eben
sehr schwer zum miteinander zu
verknüpfen sind sind beide theorien in
allen ausprägungen immer wieder bewiesen
worden also es gibt keinen zweifel daran
dass diese theorien so stimmen bei
walking ist es halt so dass er sehr sehr
theoretisch gearbeitet hat und da sehr
ins detail gegangen ist die singularität
bei schwarzen löchern sei es dass sie
eben auf dauer auch wie sich wieder
auflösen
das sind alles sehr theoretische modelle
und
ob das wirklich so stimmt werden wir
vielleicht auch gabriel angegangen oder
so sagen super wenn wir jetzt schon gar
nicht sah das super ihr könnt jetzt
einmal alle 90 sekunden eine nachricht
schreiben und das ist bei 2000 zuschauer
verkohlt ach so ok ihr könnt nicht
ständig waren gehen was sein
woran ist eine karte geschrieben er hat
halt diese krankheit a ls die ich weiß
es gar nicht ich müsste jetzt mal
nachgucken kannst immer ganz genießen
kannst du mal nachgucken weil wir haben
jetzt hier was die wie genau es was ist
man sich damit das klappt auf sich hat
auf jeden fall bedeutet dass
muskelschwäche der mal konnten sie sich
halt nicht mehr bewegen
das geht auf alle organe über es muss ja
bei ihnen einen luftröhrenschnitt
gemacht werden in den 80er jahren
weil er sonst erstickt wäre da haben die
muskeln auch eben ihre aufgaben nicht
mehr wahrnehmen können und seit diesem
luftröhrenschnitt konnte er nur noch mit
dem computer reden er konnte ich mir
selber sprechen und ich nehme an das ist
eine folge dieser erkrankung gewesen
dazu muss man sagen so alte dass die
typischen symptome sind schmerzloses
parisien bedeutet leben genauer
irgendwann erhöhung der muskelspannung
grundsätzlich kann alle muskeln parteien
betroffen werden eine ausnahme bilden
lediglich die augenmuskeln dich
schließlich das dam und der blase und
der herzmuskel schließmuskel des darms
also das funktioniert alles noch ja und
der herzmuskel ok herz muss gewürzt mit
gewesen aber bei allen anderen muskel
und erlangen ist und das kann auch kann
auch keinen wissenschaftlern kein
fachleute hervor sagen wie alles was
kommt immer auf die partnerländer
also man hat damals ihm lassen wann
genau man hat eben damals 1963 gesagt
noch fünf jahre also 1968 er sterben
sollen ja aber er hat halt 50 jahren
länger gelebt also sogar 55 jahre seit
der diagnose und ja ich gehe aus dem
bild du bist aus dem bild ja nicht nur
aus dem bild sondern du gehst irgendwo
anders in das ist schlecht
er hat das spricht mit dem computer ist
die frage gewesen wie hat das
funktioniert er hat so weit ich weiß
dass gott wie hat das gemacht ich glaube
es war mit augensteuerung ist das
gewesen es gibt ja für menschen mit
behinderung unfassliche methoden
inzwischen wie sie eingabegeräte
bedienen können und so weit ich weiß es
muss eigentlich mit augenkontakt gewesen
sein
aber das können wir mal googeln oder
während das ist ein neuer modus
natürlich immer noch schwierig warte mal
steuerung sprach hawking gebe ich mal
ein
also ehrlich gesagt ich hab's das ist
der livestream
nein noch mal steuerung sprache hawking
steuer
das hat sie jetzt 17 uhr wahrscheinlich
schon einer ein okay hier stets zeit und
wird neu sprachsystem für stephen
hawking papa papa
[Musik]
mit 76 gestorben genau einen muskel mit
einem muskel der wange steuern ok
[Musik]
interessant ja mit einem muskel der
mangel also mit einem übriggebliebenen
muskel konnte er das wohl steuern
so und jetzt kam ein neues sprachsystem
jetzt guck ich gerade mal und zwar haben
sie neue system was wird also ein
bisschen wie tastatur in smartphones wo
ich ja auch wenn ich setze schon öfter
getippt habe dann weiß die software was
ich als nächstes tippen will und kann
das vorhersehen und das wurde dort mit
[Musik]
künstliche intelligenz da mal wieder das
thema offensichtlich realisiert und wenn
du dann mehrere wörter eben kennt er von
der tastatur ich kenne es beim iphone
als ausfall hast und das dann ganz oft
eines der wörter dabei was man wirklich
als nächstes sagen will
und so funktioniert das dann ja ein
fantastisches system muss auch sagen das
ist wirklich unglaublich was es da für
fortschritte gibt bestimmte dinge da
gibt es halt keinen fortschritt das muss
man auch immer wieder sehen
bestimmte dinge sind nicht zu lösen
solche handschrifterkennung ist immer
noch nicht es gibt es nicht in gut
jedenfalls wusste ich nicht wo es das
gibt spracherkennung funktioniert immer
besser und toller und eben auch die
vorhersage von solchen dingen da gibt es
einfach immer mehr was immer besser
funktioniert aber es gibt halt auch
probleme und auch krankheiten zb die
nicht geheilt werden können wie alle es
aber auch da ist sind gibt es ja ganz
ganz große hoffnungen in richtung findet
sich der intelligenz da müssen wir mal
den den bildschirm haben und da gibt ja
auch ganz große erwartungen in ki
da haben wir auch bald schon öfter
beiträge darüber gemacht daß eben durch
ki in zukunft ganz spezielle medikamente
für den einen patienten oder die eine
patientin gefunden werden die die
bestimmte krankheit hat so dass da auch
ganz spezielle erkrankungen dies kaum
gibt geheilt werden können ohne großen
aufwand und man erhofft sich aus gibt ja
diesen diesen termin der technologischen
singularität das wäre halt wirklich in
zukunft wenn die sich so
weiterentwickelt hat die entwicklung von
neuen techniken von erkenntnisse weiter
viel viel schneller vor sich geht weil k
ii hat in der lage sein wird
daten in riesigen mengen zu verarbeiten
und strukturen zu erkennen die wir
menschen zwar erkennen können mit dem
kleinen datenmengen aber im lokal können
dann diese großen datenmengen
verarbeiten und kann dann neue
erkenntnisse gewinnen daraufhin aufbauen
und galoppiert dann quasi was die eben
entwicklung von neuen techniken
medikamente und so weiter angeht uns
menschen davon und ermöglicht eine viel
schnellere entwicklung aber werden sie
gerade eben schon algorithmus auf
youtube das kann halt auch gefährlich
sein da könnte kann es verschiedene
fehlentwicklungen geben die wir heute
noch nicht raus voraussagen können und
da hat stephen hawking auch gesagt da
sieht er eine ganz ganz große gefahr in
ki wir haben ja schon viele beiträge
über dieses thema gemacht und ich
schwanke mal so ein bisschen es gibt
also beispiel wo die sich selbstständig
gemacht hat und eine eigene grammatik
haben zwei rechner miteinander
entwickelt und konnten sich so
unterhalten dass die menschen nicht
verstehen ja das ist erstmal
ungefährlich aber es zeigt wie
schrecklich diese zeigt also mal auf was
da alles passieren kann und das kann
durchaus ganz schlimm seien deswegen
würde ich sagen gerade was kann geht die
warnungen die ihren mast ja auch und
stephen hawking ausgesprochen haben sind
nicht von der hand zu weisen und
zumindest wenn wir es einsetzen müssen
wir sehr vorsichtig sein und wenn man
jetzt den neuen kanten prozessor von
google sieht mit 72 kubitz das sind
neben teilchen und jesus teilchen kann
unendlich viele zustände annehmen und
nicht eben wie schaltkreis in dem
computer einen 0 und 2 0 und 1 und
deshalb kann kanten computer viel
schneller viel komplexere dinge
durchrechnen und da wäre dann ki auch
etwas was darauf laufen könnte und hätte
komplett neue möglichkeiten und da muss
man echt sagen ganz ganz vorsichtig sein
und dieser künstlichen intelligenz
erstmal nur wenige möglichkeiten geben
weil ich sehe da erfahre gefahren und
eben nicht wie ich ihn nass spricht von
marodierenden robotern die dann durch
die straßen gehen und menschen umbringen
diese perspektive hat er aufgebaut
und ja sie ist eben wirklich nicht von
der hand zu weisen wenn man jetzt sieht
das auch autonome waffen für armeen
entwickelt werden sollen die auch mit ki
ihre opfer zum beispiel suchen und so
weiter und so fort das ist alles nicht
so schön so kommen wir zu einer weiteren
frage die lange haben wir fast 45
minuten 10 45 minuten war dabei der
angefangen jetzt will man jetzt 20 also
wer sich gerade seit 16 minuten ich
würde sagen noch eine halbe stunde ich
würde sagen ja werde wenn sich die
fragen so so wieder erlebt dass sich
fragen okay dann dann würde ich sagen
gemacht machen aber ist dass gegen hans
john hocking ja aber wie ich würde schon
gerne noch ein bisschen über stephen
hawking dann ist das kommt ein ähnlicher
physiker stephen hawking es gibt ja wir
plötzlich zb weitergemacht über ein
junges mädchen das ich sag mal den
ähnliches nachgesagt wird wie ein stein
die junge einsteiger habe ich das video
genannt die mit anfang 20 schon
unglaubliche dinge gemacht hat was ich
auch so spannend finde daran ist dass
diese menschen ja dinge denken können
tatsächlich die viele viele menschen
nicht denken können und ich hab so ein
bisschen den eindruck das sind leute die
ihr zusatzgerät nicht hier um ihr gehirn
einfach ganz gut im griff haben und wir
sind oft sehe ich auch mich so wie wir
folgen so wie die lemminge irgendwelchen
bewegung wenn da einer sagt ja so
und so ist das dann sagen wir ja also
quasi das mache einfach mal so und
solche leute die sitzen dann wirklich
den ganzen tag denken nach mit ihrem
zusatzgerät und kommen auf ganz
verblüffende ergebnisse das finde ich
immer total beeindruckend dass es solche
außergewöhnlichen talente gibt nämlich
ich sag mal so wenn man das einmal
verstanden hat dann ein stadt
relativitätstheorie zum beispiel gesagt
war ja klar ist ja gar nicht so
unlogisch aber selber darauf zu kommen
das ist halt wirklich eine ganz andere
geschichte
jetzt würde ich aber sagen wir nehmen
jetzt mal fragen aber nicht aus dem chat
sondern von whatsup okay wie whatsapp
und haken hat die passgenau über den
link klicks und bis so ein
du bist so ich bin halt social media
manager zu stellen
übrigens klug das muss ich so
klicksafe.de auf den link den ich kannte
einen chat gepostet habe gott jetzt
läuft er aber voll
jetzt läuft er aber hier fahren wir auf
dem hier und dort könnt ihr uns jetzt
fragen stellen die wir sofort
beantworten möglichst um das heutige
thema stephen hawking und vielleicht
auch andere aber jetzt sind wir gespannt
wie das track and hier funktioniert ich
bin mal gespannt wie es ist wenn ihr uns
jetzt zu bannert mit nachrichten das
muss nicht sein dass er das tolle noch
sehr noch nicht so viele also knapp
12.000 muss man dazu sagen immer einfach
da drauf hineinschreiben
genau das ist ja wie zum beispiel
schreibt ich sage jetzt nicht welche
nummer 1 zuschauer
genau stephen hawking wurde am todestag
von galileo galilei geboren und ist am
geburtstag von albert einstein
verstorben
das ist schon was besonderes und noch
was es ist heute der tag des peace also
der tag der zahl pi
das ist diese zahl die benötigt wird um
irgendein kreis berechnungen zu machen
umfang radius und so weiter und so fort
und das ist schon ein wenig verrückt als
hätte sich stephen hawking das
ausgesucht aber da gibt es wieder leute
diese verschwörungstheorien haben bla
bla bla bla bla vergisst es gibt so
viele leute die irgendwann sterben und
geboren werden
ich sag mal das hätte auch so ein zufall
hätte auch an einem anderen tag
passieren können
das ist ich glaube nicht an solche also
ich find's toll und es hat was
romantisches oder was auch
verheißungsvolles was sehr positive so
ein schönes dass wir uns diese tage
damit merken können
geburtstag von albert einstein ist auch
der todestag von stephen hawking
das ist wirklich ganz darin soll das
witzige ist wie viele zuschauer haben
wir gerade wir haben gerade 2200
zuschauern die webseite es darum welche
webseite es dann klick zum punkte seite
an seite da uns ja bin ich alle
gleichzeitig könnt ihr euch mal bitte
abstimmen untereinander ja jetzt gerade
videos ich will doch nicht gleichzeitig
darauf klickt kann man sich noch mal
abstimmen
gibt das nicht her ist dass du jetzt
leiht hab ich das ja es gibt das ist ja
der hammer das ist ja wirklich der
hammer wird sich das denn nur 2000
zuschauer aus heute heißt es wieder sagt
jetzt ist wieder da ist es war
wahrscheinlich kurzfristig mal ne das
ist wirklich unterhaltsam
welches ist meine lieblings theorie von
stephen hawking kommt jetzt gerade auf
whatsapp die frage also ich finde schon
diesen informationsverlust der der
schwarze löcher das ist wirklich also
auf die idee muss man ja mal kommen weil
er ist darauf gekommen dass es das ist
verschränkte teilchen geben muss an der
grenze das ereignis horizontes und das
eben
teile dieser verschränkten teilchen
außerhalb die seite des horizonts
geraten können und dann eben das ist die
hawking strahlung und dann das schwarze
loch verlassen können
das habe ich jetzt ganz grob erklärt ihr
könnt gerne noch mal nachgucken und in
die kommentare schreiben
auf youtube aber ich finde diese idee
dass und dann kommt halt sehr viel folgt
demnach darauf kommt ja auch diese idee
dauer darauf folgt auch diese idee des
holografischen universums von dem er
überhaupt nicht wissen ob sie irgendwas
mit der realität zu tun hat oder eben
nicht
finde ich aber absolut begeistert und
auch überhaupt auf die idee zu kommen so
was erstens sich darüber gedanken zu
machen und dann auf diese das dann eben
nach rechnen zu können und das ist schon
absolut fantastisch gucken wir weiter
das funktioniert nebenbei musste sich
auf den link drücken und möglich mit dem
handy war mandy können dann sofort ein
speichert unsere weiter fort so fort
[Musik]
hier ist eine frage von robin robin
taute auf dessen patient da müssen wir
dann immer den namen mpeg will man kann
ja man kann er redaktionsmitglied uns
bei uns werden das kriegt er alles mit
wenn dabei seid und dann beantworte ich
auch die jets viel schneller was ich mit
allen nachrichten nicht machen kann ich
lese hier wie ihr sehen könnt das ist
immer sehr leicht sogar das will ich
jetzt das kannst du nicht sehen in der
auch ich habe gesagt so also da war eine
riesen liste von nachrichten die kann
man sehen und was wollte ich sagen jetzt
ohne zu lügen genau er hat gefragt weil
was wie wird der verlust von stephen
hawking die fachwelt beeinflusse ich
glaube nicht mehr weil er eben 2009 auf
seinen lehrstuhl verlassen hat er war
nicht mehr aktiv in diesem bereich und
von daher
er hat seine arbeit gemacht das wird
glaube ich nicht mehr den
da irgendwas beeinflussen ich finde es
halt menschlich sehr schade weil es ein
vordenker war und es gibt nur wenige
vordenker die so radikal sind also
stephen hawking ist es vielleicht gibt
von der sich ja auch sehr intensiv mit
schwarzen löchern beschäftigt hat und
zum beispiel wintersteller dem kinofilm
einer der executive producer war und den
film mit entwickelt hat was wirklich
einen unglaublichen firma möglich
gemacht hat zu ersten mal wurde sehr
realistisch ein schwarzes loch
visualisiert das ist schon ganz
fantastisch oder in elenas das ist auch
einer der ist nicht nur vordenker der es
vor macher das finde ich auch ganz toll
wenn der jetzt sterben würde das werden
würde werden ein riesiger verlust weil
weil er so viel in bewegung setzt und
auch dinge machen wovon ganz viele leute
sagen das ist gar nicht möglich das
funktioniert nicht bla bla bla bla bla
und ja es ist wirklich vielleicht ein
bisschen bla bla bla bla bla und das ist
dann ja schade wenn leute so gebremst
werden ich kann es aus eigener erfahrung
sagen als ich mit online-video
angefangen habe haben mir auch ganz
viele kollegen gesagt was machst du denn
da das ist ja alles schwachsinn das
funktioniert nicht es wird ja nie und
blablabla das wie gesagt dass das mit
dem internet geht ja bald wieder vorbei
ich glaube nicht dass wir hier sagt ich
lasse mich auch nicht warum ich das zu
sagen so dass man habe nicht an das zu
viert klappe an alle schnitt von 1,0
genau hat er ja bereit im reinen aber
noch keiner habe ich habe auch schon
genau ich habe abschluss von 1,6 aber
das ist auch alles ich bin ein
abiturient mit führerschein also ich hab
keine aber einstufung ich hab kein aber
ich habe keinen führerschein
ich hatte einen hauptschulabschluss ohne
führerschein aber wird jetzt machst du
bei uns ja ja
nein also thomas wird hier auch
ausgebildet und das finde ich auch ganz
wichtig dass man jungen leuten nicht nur
aus sagt ihre energie und was sie an
tollen ideen haben die thomas hat
sondern auch was mit gibt und die
wichtigste lektion die ich jedem immer
nur gebe jetzt kann man wirklich ein
bisschen ab ist wie holt man ein kabel
richtig auf das ist nämlich gar nicht so
leicht wenn man das nämlich falsch macht
dann gehen die kabel ich mal ganz schön
kaputt da kommen wir später zu so genau
ich habe aber eben kein studium beendet
habe aber journalismus von der pike auf
gelernt war jahrelang der porta beim wdr
in köln hat radio gemacht ohne ende ganz
viel live reporter war ich ab fernseh
gemacht ohne ende und ohne ende seminar
gemacht und sonst was also ich sage mal
informations bearbeitung und korrekte
wiedergabe das ist so mein mann beruf
das muss auch sagen ist kein job es ist
ein beruf und das kommt von berufung ich
mache das sehr gerne ich möchte dass und
wenn dann unter den klicks um videos zum
beispiel steht
hey danke dass du solche videos machst
ohne dich hätte ich jetzt mich nicht
entschieden zum beispiel für mathe oder
physik leistungskurs oder ich habe mich
wegen dir dafür entschieden dann finde
ich das ganz toll dann ist das etwas wo
ich sage hey ich habe meine arbeit so
gemacht wie ich sie mir vorstelle ich
habe einen menschen dazu bewegt etwas zu
tun was meiner meinung nach wirklich
auch etwas ist ein weg ist der zu ganz
tollen zielen führt wie man eben zum
beispiel bei stephen hawking sieht dass
es absolut inspirieren so eine
persönlichkeit und das ist so ein
bisschen tragisch jetzt wird gefragt was
ist mit rocking ja eigentlich wäre diese
frage stellt der muss auch dieses video
gesehen sehen
der livestream heißt doch stephen
hawking jemand hat dann irgendwie heute
nicht in der außen recht belebt ja
unterhalten wenn das noch nicht mal den
titel nicht dass stephen hawking ist
also gestorben und ja die ganze ich sag
mal wissenschaftsgemeinde das kann man
glaube ich wirklich so sagen weltweit
ist erschüttert dass er von uns gegangen
ist und es ist schon wirklich ein
bisschen tragisch und
also ich muss ehrlich sagen wir sind
sollten morgen die tränen in die augen
gekommen und ja das war's wird gefragt
wo kann man sich bei uns zu einer
ausbildung bewerben kann man nicht mal
wir sind keine ausbildungsstätte ja also
man kann doch dort wird doch doch ich
darf ausbilden darf natürlich darf da
ich habe genügend berufserfahrung ja
okay dann aber auch in der
berufserfahrung aber da muss dann nur
noch irgendwas bei der ihk oder so was
muss ich jetzt beim zweiten auszubilden
machen aber auch die spiele sind auf
jeden fall megafon und ich glaube man
kann sich bei uns tatsächlich nicht wie
im moment haben wir keinen platz für ein
auszubilden es kann in zukunft mal
anders sein aber im moment sitzt liest
du aber hier kommentare waren genau so
genau sieben hawking ist gar nicht auf
die schwarzen löcher gekommen dass es
hier eine frage sondern albert einstein
der hat halt im rahmen der
relativitätstheorie
da geht es ja einmal um die die
geschwindigkeit mit der man sich
fortbewegt und zum einen zum anderen die
gravitation die gravitation ist ja keine
kraft es keine anziehungskraft es gibt
keine erdanziehungskraft sondern die
gravitation ist eine krümmung der
raumzeit und daraus hat er hergeleitet
dass wenn die masse einen bestimmten
eine bestimmte menge überschreitet sie
in sich zusammenstürzen muss wenn sie in
sich zusammenstürzt dass dann das licht
keine chance mehr hat zu entweichen
damit auch die materie natürlich nicht
und dann so etwas wie ein eben etwas
absolut dunkles entstehen muss denn da
wo kein licht mehr raus kann das muss
dunkel sein und das muss dann ein
schwarzes loch sein und alles muss in
einem punkt zusammen stürzen
das hat er eigentlich herausgefunden
aber er hat gesagt das kann es gar nicht
geben ich glaube nicht daran dass ist zu
unmöglich und dann hat sich im laufe der
zeit immer klarer herausgestellt es muss
diese schwarzen löcher geben und hawking
hat durchgerechnet und ist eben auch auf
diese singularität gekommen und konnte
die nachweisen wobei es ist jedoch noch
nicht klar
wir wissen nicht was in einem schwarzen
loch ist bisher eine eben berechnung
wahrscheinlich gibt es diese
singularität singularität heißt es ist
ein unendlich kleiner punkt in dem sich
die komplette materie die in ein
schwarzes loch gestürzt ist
zusammenballt weil atome zerfallen wird
zerstört es können keine atome mehr
entstehen und deswegen ist es möglich
dass diese im schwarzen loch ebendieser
eine umfassen sich kleine unendlich
kleinen punkt entsteht und das ist in
allen schwarzen löchern so auch in den
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern wie
zum beispiel sah gitarrist stern im
zentrum unserer galaxie der milchstraße
nur der ereignishorizont also die
grenze ab der das licht aufgesogen wird
und nicht mehr heraus kann die wird halt
immer immer größer aber der punkt die
materie in der mitte die bleibt quasi
gleich klein nur die masse dieser
materie
die wird immer größer das ist wirklich
eigentlich fast unvorstellbar wie so ein
schwarzes loch aussieht wissen wir nicht
arbeit ja genau ist soll das mitte des
jahres so heraus genau das mitbekommen
mitte des jahres werden die aufnahmen
des größten teleskope der welt des event
horizon teleskops was aus vielen vielen
teleskopen weltweit zusammengestellt
wurde und diese teleskope haben über
zehn tage das schwarze loch in der mitte
unserer galaxie beobachtet nun aus all
diesen aufnahmen wird dann werden dann
aufnahmen des schwarzen loches
beziehungsweise natürlich dessen was da
rum passiert zusammengestellt das wird
ein sehr interessantes bild weil es
natürlich wie eine langzeitbelichtung
ist was in der natur der sache liegt
also das heißt wenn man nachts zum
beispiel den himmel fotografiert und die
kamera einfach auf dauer aufnahme stellt
dann sieht man dann irgendwann so
kreisende sterne weil sich die erde halt
dreht übrigens auch da sollte man sich
mal überlegen warum der himmel auf der
einen seite der erde so aus ist auf der
anderen seite so und warum das alles
kreist wenn die erde flach wäre wäre das
nicht möglich sprich die erbe kann nicht
flach sein und davon gibt es 108
tausende dinge die hier auf der erde nur
so sein können wenn sie eine kugel ist
und ich verstehe flach adler nicht so
das geht mir nicht in meinen kopf hinein
wie man so einen schwachsinn glauben
kann so ja tatsächlich ich habe hier
werde ich gefragt wie ich von stephen
hawkings tod erfahren habe ich glaube
genau das hat mir auf whatsapp eine
zuschauerin geschrieben
vanessa heißt sie und ich war also ich
hatte überhaupt nicht mitbekommen
und dann sehe ich diese nachricht und ja
ich war wirklich es hat mich von den von
aus den socken gehauen das war wirklich
sehr traurig weil irgendwie stephen
hawking gehört dazu damit hat es
irgendwie hatte das keiner offen schirm
und ja es war es ist wirklich es ist
wirklich sehr sehr traurig also ich soll
es eher reduziert versuche ich mal neben
- 15 minuten 10 - 15 minuten wobei es
gibt kollegen damit sie natürlicher
sprechen schreiben sie sich in ihre
manuskripte rein und sprechen diese
erste ja natürlich haben es leute die
können so perfekt moderieren die sagen
ein knie und dann schreiben du dich sich
das in die skripte rein so dass wieder
die frage was mit haut legen ja hawking
ist gestorben
und wenn du das video irgendwie
mitmachen das hatte ich nicht doch hätte
man kann über patran redaktionsmitglied
bei clixoom werden
und da gibt es ganz verschiedene ist ein
paar taschengeld kann man schon ist es
so dass ich mir die nachrichten auf
jeden immer durchlese und immer
beantwortet dass es super und das ist
eigentlich ganz cool so
- 15 minuten gut dann würde ich sagen
gehen wir dann doch mal wieder - 12
rüber zu youtube und den kommentaren
dort zu fangen ist manchmal das
interview
also erstens ihre playlist wollte ich
also auf simples gibt mit stephen
hawking finde ich super machen wir drei
vier hinter das video dran wenn man
offline auf leinwand und und an die
anderen videos auch das ist eine super
idee dass wir das alles mal
zusammenstellen und interviews vermisse
das waren schon absolute highlights hat
mir riesig spaß gemacht
wir wollten nur über hocken reden ja ich
vergessen leider nicht gemacht
ich vermisse es aber so ist es auch gut
es gibt halt immer wieder neue
entwicklungen und ja wer an wer so kann
man ein bisschen anders vorgestellt aber
das muss es dann auch gewesen sein
es leben geht weiter und es geht es
wirklich und es passiert immer wieder
was neues und wer an dem alten hängen
bleibt
das ist einfach das blöde nicht hängen
bleiben immer wieder was neues machen
und ja es ist eigentlich 24 7 auf
abwegen seinen abonnenten nein ich bin
nicht 24/7 ich bin auf gar nichts 24/7
ich lasse auch einfach mal den lieben
gott einen guten mann seine mache gar
nix auf social media das kann ich
inzwischen arbeitet kraft gekostet aber
dass man muss es machen sonst geht man
kaputt wenn man immer online ist das
geht nicht durchgehend online geht nicht
gut da wird ja es werden mehr
leistungskategorie swisscom gang auf
jeden fall auf jeden fall und er gleich
sehr sehr sehr geile technik und ich
glaube jetzt haben wir jetzt auch wieder
sehr spontan gemacht einfach spontan
gesagt hey stephen hawking ist so ein
thema da müssen wir nicht was live
machen
beim nächsten mal wenn wir dann auch
noch fotos vorbereiten werden videos
einspielen können werden gäste haben als
das kann man jetzt mit dieser technik
machen
aber uns war es wichtig dass jetzt mal
auszuprobieren was zuerst bei deinem
kanal thomas neben jetzt gemacht und
dann nachdem das und das haben wir hier
ja und danach hatten wir ein paar
technische probleme aber jetzt sind wir
tatsächlich glaube ich bislang noch kein
super problem aufgekommen
es wäre ja schlimm ist noch gucken wie
das mit vielleicht drei kameras
passieren weil eigentlich haben wir noch
eine dritte aber das leider der akku
leer
das haben sie nicht sagen muss nach das
ist sowas denn ja man hätte ja auch mal
die ladegeräte haben können und so das
ist richtig aber dieses jahr eine
ausbildung das ist richtig gut welches
porno song gefällt euch am liebsten
brauche gerade eine neue muse oder das
glaube ich jetzt überhaupt nicht unser
thema ja wichtige frage warum dachte er
dass es keinen gott gäbe es ist ja
sowieso die ganz große frage ist warum
existiert etwas und da man phänomen
warum gibt es überhaupt religion
religion gibt es ja in allen kulturen
auf der welt unabhängig voneinander sind
sie überall entstanden auch bei den maya
gab's religionen die ihr mit uns
überhaupt nicht in kontakt waren überall
gab es religion und religion war nicht
dazu da das unerklärliche zu erklären
weil sonst hatte man nichts wann war was
gesehen und wusste nicht was es war und
hat sich verdammt nochmal ständig die
frage was ist das denn aus dem später
dann die wissenschaft entstanden ist
aber bis zu diesem zeitpunkt gab es nur
die möglichkeit religion es muss etwas
übernatürliches sein was sich dadurch
zeigt und das fängt an eben mit den
sternen mit der sonne und so weiter und
so fort aber dann wurde das ja
wissenschaftlich geklärt und das ist
übrigens noch mal eine ganz interessante
geschichte galileo galilei musste ich
gesagt nee musste ja schwören vor dem
papst und quasi abbitte leisten und
sagen nein
die erde dreht sich nicht um die sonne
das stimmt nicht was er herausgefunden
hatte mein hawking hawkings etwas
ähnliches passiert johannes paul der
zweite kniete vor hawking nieder bei
einer konferenz im vatikan und bat ihn
ich diese theorie zu veröffentlichen das
eben das universum eine viel der
missionale kugel ist und der urknall
nicht der anfang ist sondern ein punkt
auf dieser kugel womit ja dieser moment
des erschaffen nicht mehr den gibt es
nicht mehr
und das ist für die kirche ein großes
problem weil in diesem punkt da
existierte der glaube noch dass das war
das für die kirche war es das letzte
unerklärliche und es gibt es durch diese
theorie nach dem hawking nicht mehr sagt
das war immer so das universum existiert
immer der urknall ist nur eben einen
punkt auf dieser oberfläche
ich möchte es mal so interpretieren wir
hier
ihrig thomas haben eine ganz bestimmte
vorstellung von zeit wir glauben wir
sind geboren wir werden immer älter und
das sterben irgendwann alles läuft in
alle richtungen wie ein fluss es fließt
in eine richtung was aber wahrscheinlich
überhaupt nicht der fall ist nur wir
können in diesem universum nicht anders
existieren wir würden ja verrückt werden
werden wir in der lage wären zum
beispiel die vergangenheit zu gehen und
unser großvater umzubringen
dann hätten wir ein kleines problem denn
das würde vieles nicht mehr
funktionieren ich glaube also
intellektuell wir könnten das gar nicht
denken aber auch praktisch wäre das gar
nicht möglich deswegen gibt es diese
zeit für die summer lebewesen für für
individuen im universum ohne dieses
system derzeit die in eine richtung
gerichtet wäre könnten die nicht
existieren aber das nimmt eben rocking
für das universum generell nicht an und
spricht von einer imaginären zeit das
wäre die richtige zeit und die
funktioniert aber ganz anders
und damit gibt es keinen grund mehr von
gott er sagt das ist das ist das was ist
das universum es wurde nicht erschaffen
es gibt keinen gott und punkt so und das
ist für die kirche ein ganz ganz großes
problem
ich finde es gibt noch genügend
unerklärliches aber es wird halt erklärt
mit mystischem was nicht erklärbar ist
also es wird einfach über das
unerklärbare etwas mystisches
mir ist jetzt gerade unser kater
christian im team christian halli hallo
der halo christoph geschrieben hat mit
einem daumen nach oben auf youtube.de
aber das ist noch mal ein ganz wichtiger
punkt religion und wissenschaft religion
existiert durch unerklärliche dinge
religion erklärt sie mit
ich sag mal fantasiegeschichten und die
frage ist natürlich was hat die fantasie
mit einem wirklich echten höheren leben
zu tun
wir wissen es nicht es gibt es ist gibt
es nicht ist es nur eine
verschwörungstheorie
es ist sehr schwierig ist muss jeder
mensch für sich selber entscheiden und
ich finde es gibt gar nicht dieses muss
diesen unerklärlich im moment geben ich
finde es sowieso ohne gleich für mich
ist das unbegreifbar gibt es parallel
universen gibt es nur dieses eine
universum existieren wir in elf
dimensionen stringtheorie und so weiter
das ist alles so unfasslich
unbegreiflich ich finde es gibt genug
gründe um eine religion zu haben
man muss ich glaube ich nicht am
burgwall festhalten was haben wir noch
im langsam oder sie das ist ja der
langsam modus als dass ich die leute
wissen welches das nicht geben
das ist schreiben wir die wahnsinnigen
werben gerade 2200 zuschauer durch
kennen und haben schon 16.000
wiedergaben gehabt 16.000 verschiedene
wiedergaben das sind durchschnittlich
hält mehr und 15 minuten 30
durchschnittliche watch teil
das ist absolut einig war immer ein sehr
großer kritiker von livestreams weil ich
befürchtet hatte dass nur sehr wenige
zuschauen wenn ich aber jetzt sehe das
zum erst zum einen eben 2000 menschen
die ganze vergleich zeitig sehen und die
bisher eben zum beispiel schon 16.000
das gesehen haben ist das schreibt
gerade einer im chat unfasslich also das
finde ich wirklich das ist schon eine
ganz tolle geschichte und live ist halt
immer nochmals etwas ganz ganz anderes
hier kann ich mein kein skript
vorbereiten
hier habe ich alles im kopf also hier
gibt es keinen teleporter sonst arbeite
ich mit dem teleporter weil es muss man
zeigen unseren kleinen blick hinter die
kulissen
die kamera irgendwo stellen die haben
wir jetzt glaub ich nicht hier stehen
so hatte ibm wo meine batterie ist
glaube ich also den kann ich euch jetzt
nicht zeigen aber hier ist halt ein text
darauf spiegelverkehrt und hier in die
kamera wird dann das iphone geklemmt mit
dem text der dann spiegelverkehrt
rückwärts von oben nach unten läuft und
dann sehe ich halt im spiegel hier seht
ihr das den text und lese den ab den
tisch vorgeschrieben hat oder eine
kollegin oder skodas ist der täter ist
ja dazu darf für die leute die
vielleicht nicht wissen wie das
funktioniert
ihr guckt direkt hier rein und lässt
direkt.de verschwendung ist eine
spiegelung genau und deswegen wird der
text auch gespiegelt auf dem iphone
angezählt und guckt ihr direkt in die
linse reihen dahinter sitzt ja und dann
guckt ihr direkt auf den text und ich
zeige es einmal demnächst werden das
akku voll ist wie es tatsächlich
funktioniert vielleicht machen wir mal
an dessen spitze
das ist eine super idee das können aber
auch wir haben ein echt nix ja genau
während in einem livestream finde ich
ist das auch die der perfekte bräuchen
der handkamera machen machen wir jetzt
nicht welche nicht bei diesen stativen
bei unserem auto wenn wir jetzt haben
kamera machen da wir mal ob ich sterben
würde ich so nicht sagen bei dem hammer
gegen das bei dem anderen weniger
sowas auf jetzt guck ich gerade noch mal
jetzt steht es glaube ich endlich ja
jetzt geht's gut ich habe es mal
angeschlossenen zu bleiben da können wir
gleich vielleicht auch zeigen wobei wir
haben wie viele noch immer noch wir
haben noch drei gefährlich und ja also
es wenn wir vielleicht nicht mehr
schaffen also ist manchmal so 1 teams ja
aber das kann man ja wir wollen ja
wirklich demnächst eigentlich wollte man
als erstes einen großen nazi machen so
drei stunden mit gesten und talk und
hats nicht gesehen weiß er aber lieber
erst ein bisschen die heimischen ja ja
klar deswegen dass er siegen haben es
heute gemacht genau genau
es kommt ja frage ist klicks um einen
unternehmen klicks und selbst ist kein
unternehmen aber das ist teil der united
creatures genau die das ganze auch
produziert genau also und das tolle ist
das muss man jetzt sagen
das tolle ist dass
klicks um sich immer besser rechnet also
es war jetzt wirklich jahre lang
wirklich ja lang sind immer maximal ich
glaube so 1000 euro eingekommen
und damit kann man so etwas kaum
finanzieren und dann irgendwann anfang
letzten jahres als youtube dann endlich
die werbung so geschaltet hatte dass sie
eher guten inhalten läuft als for trash
gingen die einnahmen nach oben seitdem
kann ich einen kater bezahlen der
wirklich das hauptamt ich mache jeden
tag ihren videos schneidet ich kann der
autorin bezahlen die zwei drittel des
skriptes schreibt und sowas wie whatsapp
war jetzt möglich was wirklich ein ganz
tolle möglichkeit ist mit euch in
kontakt zu treten weil eben nicht ein
algorithmus stört die kommunikation
zwischen euch und mir sondern ihr kriegt
jede nachricht angezeigt die ich euch
schicke und ihr könnt mir alle
nachrichten schicken nirgendwo greiz ist
ein feed oder irgendwas dazwischen ist
und deswegen finde ich es ganz gut das
ist eine teure angelegenheit muss man
wirklich sagen aber jetzt durch kathrin
wir haben heute einen spender bekommen
der wirklich den maximalbeitrag bezahlt
pro monat das ist eine hohe summe aber
dafür macht derjenige dann auch wirklich
mit er kann mit entscheiden er ist wir
machen eine redaktionskonferenz per
skype einmal im monat die mit dem
nächsten mal unbedingt anwerfen stimmt
er schon einmal genau genommen haben
jetzt wir machen einfach dann zweimal
oder sonst was eine länge für ein länger
ist egal
also das ist wirklich das tolle dass man
wirklich mitmachen kann und dadurch
vater hat mitzumachen es gibt da noch
ein paar guten buch gibt's geschenk
natürlich dass youtube for peace egal
[Musik]
wir machen events wo man auch
zusammenkommt eingeladen wird einmal im
jahr
und ja es ist eine tolle das eine engere
community und sie ermöglicht auch eben
klicks um mehr einzunehmen und das
weiter zu professionalisieren da gibt's
demnächst auch noch news wird werden es
demnächst in englisch machen da bereiten
wir jetzt alles für vor oder doch mehr
und vielleicht noch mehr
ich gehe davon aus ich gehe mal schwer
davon aus ja deswegen wird hier weil du
hattest gerade gäste angesprochen es
wird gewünscht hast du mal harald lesch
eines würde ja perfekt anpassen was man
ich habe auch jetzt mit jemandem
kollegen darüber gesprochen
der glaube ich sogar dort arbeitet also
wir sind in kontakt ich wäre zum
beispiel auch demnächst mal ein video
machen hier mit mirko drotschmann wissen
to go und solche sachen alles geplant
werden wir machen weil ich auch total
motiviert bin dadurch wie kriegst du mir
jetzt läuft das ist absolut wahnsinn
zweieinhalb millionen sowie ihr wisst ja
demnächst dass mir die haare rot färben
ist noch ein bisschen ich muss mal
gucken jetzt am wochenende so was habe
ich einen kurs beim südwestrundfunk in
baden baden
dann möchte ich jetzt nicht mit
violetten farbe aufträten ich muss mal
pokémon der perfekte zeitpunkt ist warum
da mal ein paar tage violett rum sowie
wird sich lange machen weil wir es fängt
das schon christin strange aber ja ja
also ich finde wir können langsam zur
verabschiedung kommen wenn ich hier im
die 425 minuten
das ist meine alte ich habe die zeit
immer ganz gut im kopf irgendwie und ja
das war klicks um zum zweiten mal live
super dass er so heftig mit diskutiert
habt auf klicks um auf dem live stream
im chat und auf whatsapp und das finde
ich natürlich wirklich ganz fantastisch
macht einen riesenspaß und sap so viel
dass die seite sogar kurzfristig
zusammengebrochen ist wer hätte das
gedacht ich nicht ich hätte nie gedacht
das klingt so um sich
auch nach dieser umstellung so positiv
entwickelt bin total euphorisch werde es
noch viele viele jahre machen bis ich
alt und verwurzelt bin und vielleicht
sondern so heiser bin und dann immer so
schräder also bis zum schluss fertig zu
machen
ich würde mal sagen an dieser stelle
hast du jetzt den knopf wurde den stream
abschalten kannst da war ich würde jetzt
mal sagen dass wir zusammen bis dann
bleibt an achtung in die kamera bis
dahin bleibt der höheren stimmzettel